all right it's 8:50 a.m. good morning to
people or good afternoon - to Europe
good evening to Europe a lot of people I
guess already in the chats we have
Krishna inst for InfoSec Mathias se says
have a great tournament you're all I'm
going hunting
so I say good luck well good luck with
hunting Oh afternoon from a theists Tony
to hang how's it going so the tournament
starts in nine minutes or no ten minutes
yeah I'm not entirely sure how to
mentally prepare myself woke up not too
long ago I have my tea and my hand mixed
tea from Alaska now it's past midnight
in Sydney Wow
well thanks for staying awake for us
Paul it's a normal time it's the work
day is just beginning
8:51 oh you came literally from just
watching my youtube videos nice kaigan
thanks for joining
yeah so we can all be together but also
social distance so I mean there's this
is a mass gathering of over 3,000 people
I would imagine by the end of this
tournament
there will be should should actually
have like a contest to guess the final
number of participants
I'd guess 6,000 I think it's going to
double it's cool yeah yeah I'm gonna try
and avoid the tilts
it feels like there's more pressure
because I have a whole team to to try
and carry but actually there's a few
people that maybe can can carry the rest
of us by the mix brand is is a top
player but offline there who this is hmm
okay I have a Vitamix I haven't used it
actually so recently I have juice I
forgot I'm poor juice so I've tea and
juice with Maxie not c53 thanks for
subbing um while there's close to 70
thousand players on Leech s hoping
they're able to run the tournament
without any server issues also sacrifice
87 thank you for summing with twitch
crime I appreciate that
a rubix anon says shut down from today
in Ireland except for essentials yeah
that's kind of the same case in st.
Louis most restaurants are closed every
seems like every place is closed except
for the grocery stories now if you don't
know what's happening is happening today
this is a leech off streamers battle
there's ten ten different teams that you
can join
you should join mine I think we're the
or were the underdogs I think this is
base is a based on rating average or is
it based on top twenty average it's
probably based on overall rating average
[Music]
what does this name woo woo peed on
would be done my rug
thanks for thanks for something for 2
months yeah it's the same in Germany yes
and now this now is not a bad day to
play chess when people might be traps
it's a weekend this is a weekend it's
Saturday ok so the goal for this
tournament is to finish in the top 10
among teens and then hopefully the top
hundred among among individuals we can
just see who's on these teams and
ideally would be nice to finish top
nines we're not in last place if you
want to join I have a few you have to be
part of my elite chefs fan club so you
can click the link in the chat for the
team and then go to the team battle my
pod is sharing the links chestnuts how's
it going who's back a boy thanks for the
bits yeah I'm gonna try my best
we're all gonna try our best hopefully
um going back to see who's off the team
things are loading kind of slowly
unfortunately what's the corona opening
there's a car wanna
is there a car one opening the car
wanted repertoire chest by Jay how's it
going yeah you need to stay awake oh
thank you couch is off gambits
appreciate that slumming for two months
and air Falcon sewing from the nine
months gooo yeah
[Music]
ossama the s how's it going thanks for
joining
so we have over three hundred seven
players I don't know if I can see I
can't see everyone I can only see the
top fifty the this top team needs to be
stopped this top team has I don't know
how many GM's I don't know if I'd make
the top twenty and this team also this
team is pretty like the I think the top
like five teams are really strong and
beat doc it's loving for eighteen months
that's like a year and a half
thanks so much and reasonable I almost
read that it's rosin a bowl thanks for
subbing if there is a rosin opening what
would it be I'm probably some dubious
Kabat yeah there's so many players
joining I'm a little bit concerned
I played the the weekly classical arena
yesterday and I got to play one game and
then the turn had just crashed as we
just down oh oh yeah I mean this is what
happens when you invite like the some of
the most popular streamers and then they
get all their their cult followings to
to flood the website simultaneously we
need to we need to start donating more
money Toby chess for them to upgrade
their servers vampire chicken says we're
going to crush you but not if not if
there's there's no tournaments and we
could play blindfold correspondence
this is a nice artwork I haven't seen
this page in a while actually yeah I
guess we can we can appreciate the art I
assume it should reload once the site is
is back up I know they they do take
measures when there is a very big influx
of of users on the sites they do
I think disable certain things so things
can run faster like this they disable
viewing profiles and maybe some other
things Steven this Daedalus says I
logged off to help I mean I would log
off too but kind of have a job to do
okay so it's it looks like it's back
there's already 50,000 people back I'm
drinking the the good belly blueberry
juice from Whole Foods
yeah I don't know about this we're gonna
have to wait and see can I set up an
online polling and play against chats I
think someone was working on that I
would require some knowledge of coding
but that's a cool idea oh why do I play
on me chess as opposed to chef tom i
play on chess comm occasionally most
often for their their larger events of
titled Tuesday I mean whenever they have
arena Kings we may they'll announce in
that season at some points I think
they're they're organizing an
interesting event coming up which I
don't know if it's public yet but yeah I
might have to switch switch to chess
calm for today
yeah that's failing to fetch okay let's
try again
get crops again
maybe a crashed in that's so sad yeah
the sights have different different pros
and cons in me choice I you know I think
a lot of people just really enjoy the
interface
I like the arrows it's just easier
easier to dry rose and also the study
feature oh wait oh wait where is this
coming from
what matchup eight okay we'll see what
happens
two one zero they're gonna start
we're about to find out I mean if not I
can just sit here and drink juice and
tea all day then I'll be hydrated just
weed how's it going Charlotte such a
sweet I did hear from OHS I think
whoever ooh oh I'm playing a game but it
stopped I know I know there's like this
issue like starting the tournament's
difficult because you have to start all
the games at once hopefully if if the
trimming can get going then it's
reloading and then hopefully you can run
without problems yeah the one of the
leech s mods admin said that they they
do plan to upgrade their servers pretty
soon just to account for the huge amount
of traffic Oh mol SG says lost my first
game ID because I didn't start yeah
hopefully you'll get your your rating
refund if not then you'll be slightly
lower rated so appoints will
underestimate you slightly more I guess
always have to look at the positives hmm
is this a podcast now if I just turn off
turn off everything and have no no video
now now it's a podcast do you guys
prefer a podcast I was thinking um oh
it's back is this okay let's play let's
play d4
oh wait no I lost no I won wait I'm
confused
it says I won rating points no because I
was black
oh no now people will will overestimate
me more because my rating slightly
higher this is so sad but I'm so good i
won even without making a move
yeah somehow it is black ice playing
Andre poor Andre
I won playing both colors yeah yeah my
opponents my opponent forfeited and then
I I tried showing him how to play the
first move and now it's failing to fetch
again to teach Lee just how to fetch
[Music]
yeah this this has not happened um
maybe ever in terms of this magnitude I
know like tournaments have crashed
before but I'm sure they're trying like
everything there's just so many people
that's probably I'll probably take less
of the blame
we should put most of the blame on agony
there a god Matt or however you say his
name
bringing maybe half a million
subscribers from YouTube or some
percentage of that also Akash I see
Akash
Akash was was part of my team shoutout
to Akash let's get this bread I went to
Trader Joe's a week and a half ago two
weeks ago and they were completely sold
out of bread so then I went to Whole
Foods and they still had bread cuz their
bread it's like three times as expensive
but it's nice because now I can make
toast okay um yeah shadow - Akash people
should follow him on Twitch
I think Akash is planning to stream
tomorrow if I'm not mistaken in the
meantime in the meantime tagging Tyga
use the perfect emotes what to do how's
it going taggi or maybe the the second
most perfect Emo's because we all know
what the most perfect emote is
now chefs we've almost made a deal with
Tori to give her diet coke for bread hmm
wonder which one gives you more energy
does bread gives you the carbs but diet
coke gives you the the sweetness oh
let's go back to the homepage and see
what's what's happening
everything was just loading what toasts
are you making are there different types
of toasts it's whatever a whole food
bread like the the multigrain I've been
freezing it because I don't want it to
go bad but I just put it from the
freezer into the toaster and then it
turns into toast in like a couple
minutes it's great OB just Twitter oh
that's actually yeah when anything's
down you just turn to Twitter return for
answers except that one time when
Twitter was down and then no one knew
what to do
HS Twitter okay so this is Twitter how
to pronounce Li Ches yes aha okay
because some people say like chess some
people say I lied chess okay we are
aware of time outs happening yada yada
okay that's nice nice to be aware anyway
yeah I tweeted about this that's nice
oh also there's a huge thing which
happened on the stream yesterday which I
also tweeted about but I didn't realize
in the moment actually got a nice
response on Twitter so oh is it starting
maybe it's starting
finishes in one hour failed to fetch
again
ah but yeah yesterday Peters fiddler
gifted 5 subs from the count polled
boertie without any O's and I thought it
was just a s fiddler impersonator I even
called him out that this is not sweet
ler but it was fiddler it was nice yeah
then I tweeted about it
[Music]
it's feelers say Souter says seeing
something on Twitter
also thanks to everyone for following me
on Twitter I broke five thousand
followers yesterday now I didn't really
celebrate ah okay let's let's join let's
join people have already begun what
oh maybe oh we're in we're in fifth
place let's go
I haven't even played the game yet well
I've won twice oh because of forfeit
games haha
I've won twice and then I guess I paused
matagi is too old for Twitter I thought
Twitter is a place for old people but
maybe I'm wrong
elitist org says we're trying to fix
things yeah no no worries
I'm keep I'm trying to keep people
entertained with the bread stories and
toasts and spindler fiddler stories
fiddler beat me in the the bantered
let's cut a few months ago and then then
he offered to get me beer and then I saw
him in st. Louis the following month but
I see him I was during the Tata Steel
India event he was doing commentary from
st. Louis and then all like every what
every place was closed because we were
working from like 1:00 a.m. to 9 a.m. so
there is no beer yeah what did you
[Music]
have you ever been to Chicago I grew up
on the outskirts of Chicago
never lucky 0-3 thanks for something
appreciate that for four months so yeah
it's so funny that's uh I won 2-1 two
teams without playing anything I lost
one that's hard to keep up with the chat
sorry if I'm missing any any comments
yeah for every forfeit when our team
guts we lose some too so I guess it was
completely random which team is as in
first cuz white and white would just win
every or white would lose every game Gio
Gio Gio I could I could play Gio but I
feel like I should stay here and I
appreciate this artwork more also have
another lesson 3 ah that's the symbol of
love oh those are the words of love
thanks for uh thanks for the sub for two
months yeah last time I checked there
were there were oh I'm playing I'm
playing chess yes no no I was white I
saw my name on top I thought I was black
I was white
oh that's so sad I'm losing so many
rating points and because I'm on the
higher end of the the tournament if this
keeps happening I'm gonna keep losing
rating points let's go back to this
femur battle I mean I don't care too
much about hi my online rating whatever
falls can hopefully be built back up
okay let's go where are we
yeah we're third place let's go oh
there's a game happening - between this
is a top game between two 1500s that's
great mark HC thanks for subbing oh
because those 1500s are thick probably
randomly in first place I'm playing a
game join the game I want to join I feel
left out can commentate on this game
oops Batman No why'd you say Batman also
Pellman maker welcome back
oh we chest auger is still working on it
thanks Lee chest ah don't worry in the
mean time actually but I should probably
not incentivize this right now but later
when there's less traffic on me chests
go to leech s org
I think it's / donate there's a bun from
the homepage usually in this general
vicinity and you can click and then you
can put in your your payment details
[Music]
yeah yeah kudos to whoever's in I can't
go to the turnin now but kudos to
whoever is in first place
probably got white every game or got
black I freaking that's the way to win
to be honest a chess website crashing is
a victory for chess those are really
wise words because it just means that
chesses has reached the point of
popularity that there's so many people
it's crashing a website's need to
upgrade the servers what happened to the
candidates
yeah the candidates also crashed but
that was not a victory for chess
that was that was Russia shutting down
on its air travel slightly different
circumstance and what's happened to me
here as far as I know all the players
were able to make it out of Russia
Fabiano had a legendary tweet and then
he then he got his ride on a private jet
along with you know along with some
other fidei officials and vo a complete
farce I I was looking up I put in force
into the Souris I was wondering like
what other words are similar to farce
and it came up with buffoonery I feel
like that would have been on a nicer
word for it tweets more character is but
I know buffoonery is kind of rolls off
the tongue determines over oh but I
can't I can't trust honest chess I can
only trust me Chester org and maybe
Thomas shout-out to Thomas are you
talking about to the candidates the
candidates I think because some people
were saying cancelled but technically I
think it's postponed
meanwhile I don't know about this
tournaments it's gonna be postponed or
canceled Oh agony there is a winner what
No okay again the page is loading Oh
Terman has been removed maybe oh ok
we've to leave that the previous tourney
going to try to make another one okay
nice so so good
probably because yeah this team has the
most had nine hundred and nine players
how many do we have
it's probably based on how many players
were on each team because then you're
just more likely to have more players
get lucky which is technically skill why
wins one purse to white win one percent
of the games again
yeah it's pure probability on numbers
mean all probability is numbers right
unless it's probability of words or
letters how do you draw should ask Bob
Ross or Geary or probably shook at this
point yes so they're remaking the
tournament I don't know I don't know if
Lee Chester work is watching but you can
tell me if I should incentivize people
nuts and go on the site for some time or
to keep refreshing ferociously what does
the probability of probability and if
there's any philosophers in the chats
feel free to answer do I like dark
chocolate of course I like dark
chocolate more than milk chocolate house
Lords good luck thank you
so far this tournament has been all
about luck fifth place not that above
chest network core keiko thanks for that
the Sun at tier one
yeah it doesn't talk chocolate have some
what is it some health benefits and the
super dark chocolate the one with like
no or very little sugar but it's
slightly bitter 367 on my team maybe I
can trust that number and sounds about
right
Oh Congrats to this whoever this person
is it's your boy V with 24 points that's
insane I only got four points
oh thanks so much see 13 b9v 11
I wonder what the story is behind that
name but yeah I mean it's a Saturday all
the streamers are online making their
audience play for them and the whole
world is shut down so obviously there's
gonna be more traffic to lead us and the
candidates are finished or postponed so
this chess players have nothing else to
do it probably would have been better to
run this all alongside the candidates
because then at least a lot of people
would be playing the candidates and or
watching the candidates I don't know
Chesley blames the candidates yeah it's
all Putin's fault
[Music]
stopping here Travel maybe I shouldn't
say that but that's kind of a chain
reaction is there a minesweeper know if
this computer has a minesweeper mind's
eye I would probably have to download it
I'm not gonna experiment right now chest
chest cheese cheese yeah I ran out of
cheese yesterday I brought like a nice
triangle Brie at Trader Joe's and now
it's it's gone
pots are play what's the pots are play
is this a real pots are play I'm gonna
trust your your highly suspicious Google
link
okay I can play online
what Wow okay
well can i play without the window one
moment okay it's mine sweep oh wait no
the tournament's back streamers battle
what
oh no they're recreating the tournament
oh but with me chess is back well you
make a video about the staffer that was
my most recent episode is the staffer
gambit but also I have I do have a I do
have plans stay tuned we chest is more
solid now oh that's beautiful
so let's just hold tight
I'm sure they'll yeah they they remove
the thing from the homepage yeah we're
just gonna wait and see
yeah I have to be patient
maybe it's slow for some people
depending on your internet connection
oh yeah two nights attack maybe I'll
make that when I hit a hundred thousand
subscribers on YouTube Oh was I watching
yeah there is a there is a streamer
yesterday playing chess with twenty six
thousand viewers and it was it was
fascinating the twitch kept saying
omegle ole and Pepe laughs whatever that
means and his rating was like below a
thousand I think maybe it was 1100 but
yeah it's fascinating when non chess
streamers stream shots I think he was an
overwatch streamer it was very
fascinating
hey Liam be the FM cuz you were black
good job yeah we're gonna wait for a
moment here I don't think I need to do
anything in terms of updating things on
my ends I guess people who overslept or
are accidentally joining late this is
good for them cuz now they'll be on time
they'll miss all this madness many
players got their highest-rated wins
yeah I wonder if Li Ches will gather out
to refunding those points that could
just be a nightmare to code but maybe it
wouldn't be you can access all the games
in a tournament and then just probably
write a for loop and then I plus plus
and have something to just refund it's
all about the for loops and sometimes
the while loops so what to do let's
watch a game or I could play a game but
I don't want to crash the website do I
dare play one game I could solve a
puzzle let's solve a puzzle I'll answer
questions too am i a programmer outside
of chess I was a programmer in a past
life
I take a rook you take a rook and then
take another rook and then get meted
that means that's mates Wow takes takes
takes takes pin meat so it's highly
crucial to not get me no don't take her
I'm I mean I'm thinking just queen takes
and then not get mated I mean what else
to do like what are the other candidate
moves we have to we have to take here
and then somehow meet rook d8 I mean
also take with a pawn maybe oh but lose
our queen let's not lose a queen
this is a good wake up wake up exercise
and we can also take the rook and then
start checking but the King just walks
up and we don't have any more checks oh
but we're up oh maybe that's that's
probably the solution because we would
be up a rook there it's still oh wait a
minute no we check on g7 then take with
the Queen so here here here we win the
night and we defend everything we're up
a rook let's do it yeah let's go okay
yeah cuz Queen f7 King g6 maybe it's
still a little bit murky that was nice
good job to whoever found that
just weep says ah so you doing chesses
karma what is that isn't everything in
life karma in some way or another even
karma dumpster who is an occasional
viewer to the stream got 10 points Oh
on the way to breaking 2600 yeah my
first my first major in college was math
and computer science I should monitor
the homepage waiting I'm just waiting
for a VHS org to join with updates
or is this a new one always
what says in 60 mm oh did join or did it
start
yeah it looks like this is a one okay um
let's join what's driving for my team
okay um it's going yeah let me let me
update the commands everyone joined
before the other teams do commands at
its team battle let's go
okay so team team battle command will
get you the the thing let's play
Sicilian okay I don't know if I'm
mentally prepared for this but let's
play chess layout looks to be okay
oh I didn't update it correctly da Queen
d3 queen d3 is a a reasonable move I
think I'll take no she forgot the theory
here can some to some nod know how to
update it so now I'll just do it maybe I
won't let's stay focused
[Music]
[Music]
I hope that worked play play d5 wait
this is an hour long tournament well I
can see oh this is a new feature I can
see what team they're on so I'm playing
someone on on a god notorious team keep
wanting to say Agra Demeter so we have
to we have to very much take this person
down Bishop d6 t6 actually looks nice
thinking Bishop g5 I play Knight d7 like
there should be seven gonna stay
flexible
now the bishops are lined with some nice
things I have a five here I think I'm
okay with this line takes takes diagonal
would open
yeah it's gonna be positional though oh
wait I have to defend this so I'll just
take and castle I have slightly where's
pollen structure but it's a game the
bishop wants to be here and pressure
stuff pawn probably wants to be on c4
played there should be five discourage
but should be to rook c8 you mites gonna
play c4 first unfortunately or not so if
I play c4 it makes most sense there's
some line where it's important the
bishop controls B aids after it takes
takes takes takes takes takes there's no
Rock VA means maybe g6 or each six I
don't know h6 first
rook b5
I wanted to play this and not worry
about this we're up d5
in Quincy six is interesting some idea
at five so takes takes maybe about six
yeah and this is only open files so why
not pile up
[Music]
I'm not sure if I want to play c3 makes
some sense play c3 I'm closing things
down it probably takes with Queen I'll
take with her it's interesting because
we both have pawns fixed on dark squares
on the Queen side
so both pawns are potential weaknesses
and but also potential strengths I'm
threatening just two in this Bishop c8
could help make that happen
[Music]
the bishop is actually very good just
defending the pawn if we're gay one can
i play work t2 maybe not so let's start
with this or actually
it's a tricky move let's play this first
very sneaky so my threats this because
the pawns over works
that's playoff six
unfortunately I'm not making much
progress I'm just losing the pollen for
nothing that's really unfortunate I have
to resort to dirty flagging
play King kini seven
interesting
what what what was that was Rick takes
g7 that's such a nice gift it's like
waking up tomorrow and it's Christmas it
was completely unexpected
ok good job to whoever won let's go
let's play off the berserk and let's
play eat four oh they changed a time to
two hours okay so this is gonna be a
maybe longer than normal tournaments
I'll play this b3 French line let's play
play c3 trying to open up the position
take and develop it's trying to pressure
the center law the pressure against d4 I
think I can even a pawn here I don't
know if I want to win a pawn like we
need to first 93 would have been not the
best move
hunter-killer one in four moves good job
keep it up so I'm playing oh I'm playing
someone from the penguin fan club yeah
we need to take the Penguins down this
is a actually playable move as if takes
I I take here first and then take and
then get the dark squares I'll have this
e-file to have them how's it going the
ice how's it going
Jacob yeah good to see people joining if
you're just joining you missed all the
madness there are a lot of issues but
the term is now underway trying to
interpret the standings does this mean
we're in first place I don't know if
this move no it doesn't quite work so
let's just take and then probably win
this pong somehow 94 I could move I
desert to move quicker ie 5
play queen here okay so attacking a pawn
let's win the pawn
I'm not sure if that was the best
decision but I'm trying oh that's a free
night okay that was nice
this is a playable Moodle there are some
traps too Frick CA there's this move
which i think is about to happen yeah
okay
now it's just a matter of technique and
taking more free stuff let's push pawns
the pawn storm is real and g5 g six
ideas okay let's go so we're in fourth
place not bad but chestnut we're close
very close behind there's gonna freeze
from the tournament unclear
oh okay let's play what's Boozer tonight
yeah anyone below twenty one hundred
members irking let's play another one of
these lines plea five eats COO yeah
welcome back Brian thanks for still
being here okay so yeah it's actually
kind of a closed position which the
French player is probably happy about
I'm gonna try and play quickly and
confidently let's play g4 yeah I was
thinking about 94 but it wasn't sure
that's probably a better move yeah so
black one connect four of I probably
have to take 93 so am i my nice double
Fein cattle g6 is kind of the main
targets it's been a chief 5 tagging you
6 unleashing the bishop 9g is just this
this and overpower the e pawn rook a e1
yeah I could trade districts f5 maybe
coming at some points can just take
there ok so winning upon probably
trading Queens and then king of sevens
play play this move maybe not a 5 coming
interesting
Paula wants to win upon its defend
not sure about this but just trying to
apply as much pressure as possible it's
interesting line if this I have it
doesn't quite work let's play like this
move I really wanted to play this move
but I think there were some issues with
that
Wow yeah trying to construct some some
sort of meaning that let's play this
move such a confusing position
thanks for the bit soggy oh very nice
keep it up before it's such a weird
position and 97 I want to play g5 with
hings a night and now let's play g5 58
expected play this move so I want to
play g6 and then win the night play this
and then this yeah we're just training
it's still a nice position yeah let's
get our tog II bits or tog II tog II
bits and tight emotes and free nights
good try that's a dirty b3 move and I
want to win this pawn and then this is
gonna be mates okay let's go no time to
waste still in fourth place not bad good
job Lane from wired with 14 points okay
I'm not gonna be zerk this game play c5
just try and stick us some reasonable
opening time on a Sicilian
yeah we're just actually playing a main
line here there's a g5 of Queen e5 is
interesting 25 9 of 3
let's play this move and then retreat I
can't complain
some idea of this know that stings a
piece maybe 95 don't know why it was
about to play that Paul wants to play
off four of each six yeah good move I
have to move back it's an interesting
structure probably be five there should
be seven I don't just want to Castle
queenside as quickly as possible
hmm it might be hard to do
Queen g7 is coming that's gonna be very
hard to do I've King f8 it's such a
scary move but probably necessary
stopping Queen g7 and thankfully that
file is closed when h4 that's a great
move I'm King g7 but then rook after
three Wow and she don't know what to do
here I'm in big trouble already
King East seven there's e5
maybe that's why I have to go for though
it's not gonna end well I have to sack
on e5 and I'm like Queen g5 probably at
least I'm kind of still sort of alive
not really have to take there because
the 95 pulling misses it but it's not
gonna matter so punny finds it so the
question is whether or not to resign
it's not resigned just yet oh now it's
probably time to resign unless I still
have some any chance of hope I ship here
trying to stir up some counterplay
hoping that aplenty forgets the Bishop
exists but yeah it's time to resign mmm
mouth shots because I want to play this
and rooks he - I was hoping for this
move yeah let's resign okay husband
fortune that was my first loss opponent
played very well it's queen g4 move with
a very strong attack what to do there's
a little site down again no
okay teams in fifth place let's try and
stay solid unlike last game okay playing
my pet a six line let's play this move
LVN two kids I'm still wanted to talk
the top 20 players very nice nice to
hear
keep it up like there's a bit of g6 in
this move before might come but it's one
way to get the bishop hair interesting
so I have Bishop f4 idea Bishop g4 soon
so tacking the rook
yeah II five debating between 27 and
Queenie six like when you saw our
Queenie six idea queen g4 maybe the
Queen will sit here and then the bishop
will come in or the bishop can come in
here this opponent has been me before I
have to get revenge so I have this move
I could take on just wins the pawn at
least it's crashing through with the
attack because if takes I just take here
it takes here I could take with Queen
now the Knights hit the pawns hit so
decent moves
probably have to take okay you can play
b5 and go for a five
yeah a five we'll make this kind of
structure crumble ooh
the smooth idea a - like if takes a -
I'm guaranteed to Queen and the goal is
to keep the pawns so the best approach
may be this move if takes I play too
rook b3 probably still a - maybe this
move first
if takes I have a - still
yeah now it's time to bring the king
yeah this is completely winning and come
off the King I'd basically have a freer
up to and do whatever I want with I'm
actually very happy to see the chat is
very quiet because that means everyone's
focused on their games
good job chat okay let's go
is there anyone watching who's just not
playing just purely watching ooh
we're in seventh place yeah we kinda
think we got the head start but try and
stay strong whoa it's it's a it's a
hammer hammer join my team use a team
the team command and then the team
battle command the hammer would be the
ultimate weapon let's mazurka thank you
for I mean I understand if you just want
to enjoy the show but you should oh I
just blender client kind of I mean it
would be disappointing if the hammer was
not put to use let's play let's play b3
there should be to some idea okay let's
take with pawn yeah I just wanna attack
with everything let's play rook up to 84
can be annoying let's move
yeah points being slightly annoying this
pawns in danger they should be too
TACA bishop calculating oh I could just
take it doesn't quite work but kind of
works the rook is sliding this place
takes takes I don't know let's get the
Queen to a better square I just want to
go for some attack maybe 95 Queen g3
okay time to take I'm confused here I'll
play rookie to over to find the pawn and
then prepare Queen g3 36 seconds already
not the best time management
probably a decent move defend the pawn
not what I wanted
oh there's a trap if takes takes takes
iv5 can save my pawn yes okay now I'll
win material here don't think there's
much counter play and there's a smooth I
take let's take care fighting this right
here is coming or rook here start with
this move rook here I have this move and
rook team one now rook to you one maybe
King h2 is nice because if I were to
take Queen takes with check and then it
goes back
but King h2 Queen see for a while okay
so now let's just win take care of top
the rook attack the pawn and win this
pawn first preserve the night maybe go
for meats
okay house mice OHS wave is playing for
penguin what no that's okay that's okay
well we'll be we'll be the most
successful team without any mediums
maybe do we have any GM's on our team
we've no GM's on our team
okay let's reverse and let's play let's
play super aggressively Johnny
bothwell's thinks for the sub for three
months you're playing Stafford gambit Oh
Bishop c4 loses loses brutally to this
ok this is nice
let's Stafford have it for the win let's
take here a salon 18 thanks for subbing
yeah this is a great opening trap the
staffer gambit it's laced with with
landmines and trucks well maybe we have
some secret genes on the team but it
takes maybe just King d8 good safe and
then if takes and I'll win the bishop an
end if I were to take there is Queen f3
annoyances the Queen still attacked so
there's no time for D for Oh pots are
play shout out to pots or clay let me
make pops I play a VIP oh wait was wrong
[Music]
sneaky
I need some focus here I mean take sirs
teenage - I could be missing something
very obvious but I'm not seeing it
I take C for also interesting eh -
Bishop d6 start with this I have to
check this afterwards
seventy-six I could just take an IG
three yeah that's probably simplest
expecting on this so takes night g3 I
want to play Bishop c5 but I'll go for
this I'm not sure if I had anything
better there oh I forgot to make pots or
play a VIP leading the tour kind of high
on her team
okay so things are attached and in the
end I'll be up the exchange
yeah if you ask for a VIP that's one way
to not give it VIP ooh okay there's a
g5i of this smooth sort of Chuck v g6
rookie 802 do take a pawn doesn't quite
work let's go back and friend this pawn
sneaky
oh let's not remove that there's rook g2
okay let's go
hey G Speights won against an 1800 good
job keep it up playing some mots
American let's play London think I've
raised my threshold too busy working
against players any player below 2200 b6
b6 is kind of slow Joey 5 interesting
it's taken Bishop g5 I was gonna say
usually black wants to expand black on
sequence like Castle here let's play
this move so I have lights where control
I'm doing Bishop h6 start this maybe
even this also 92 idea Knight c3
interesting haiji for idea h5 there's a
path for you just like Bishop g2 next
Kapow
thanks Auggie each five that's a very
pleasant position let's take yeah I kind
of have to tree it down
unfortunately I get the alpha0 pond
oh it probably wasn't great for me but I
wouldn't be six at least it's not gonna
need it
I'll play a three-eyed workout the one
I've this move I see foreign King a4o
let's focus on this game though I'll
worry about things afterwards I win this
pawn also c5 just a passport
let's go to tournaments does it turn
actually down though let's hope not I
was a nice game um
so win-win at least it might be down
good job
Vlad whoever this is Vlad ji-ji-ji 92
it's a it's a rabbit in the Brian the
Brian the rabbit rabbits Oh wad oh it's
Vlad Oh shadow Vlad it's some I know you
there's so many Vlad's in the world it's
hard to sometimes distinguish between
them s oh I I caught one of your streams
a while ago I think Charlotte - Vlad
let me VIP I have eat some people - VIP
VIP Vlad Jean right - yeah if I know you
in real life you're more likely to get a
VIP go back to tournaments hopefully
kind of yeah Vlad and I were on the same
team at some point in time same with me
and Akash actually today we're all we're
all on the same team right
me VIP Brian - also new VIPs today Brian
the rabbit rabbit how I spelled that
correctly
hey it's back good job me Ches so I have
my kind of deserting streak I lost
someone game see who's in first maybe
maybe not
[Music]
I think there's there might be a limited
number of VIPs I can actually give out
I'm not sure how it works does a server
down oh I I hope I'm black the next game
just so my opponent forfeits see
[Music]
Oh to force 10 we mad at the 2018 World
Championships interesting I was in
London
oh thanks Brian oh yeah I spelled it
correctly because it's it's confusing
because rabbit has rabbit has to bees
and rabid has 1b that's a really good
rating I should be on the 2700 list
quick give us lessons I'm doing terrible
I mean I'm not gonna like teach you how
to play like a GM in just a few minutes
but it's very important just to stay
focused really when you play blitz you
want to think on your opponent's time
and really try and anticipate their
moves and a big strategy of a blitz
especially at lower levels is to just
try and minimize blunders to play
intuitively play quickly and play
solidly I know some players like have
styles of attacking that's okay too but
yeah you want to you want to try and
minimize as many blunts as possible
because that's usually what determines
what schemes and conserve time because
that's also what determines what schemes
ok so I need to bring up my dog and
teach me chess how to fetch
whoa it's it's hammer thanks for subbing
hammer Charlotte's a hammer she's also
active streamer
I mean let me make it hammer come in
[Music]
[Music]
talkies if only you can flip those to
put those two numbers I would be ideal
yeah is it working for anyone that was
let's um go here let's go back to the
tournament at least try to that's not
yeah I think usually at this time
there's probably close to 70,000 people
but maybe some people are yeah this is
just the server is having issues it's
like it's a perfect storm for a beach s
I was saying this before but it's a
Saturday it's like all these streamers
gathering their audiences especially a
god matter and then it's it's a whole
the whole world being shut down but okay
yeah here's a donate link you might not
want to do it now because I don't know
how quick the server will be to accept
your money but you'll each essence
purely run on on support from the
community so I encourage it if if you
have a few extra dollars to spend
aha yeah Amanda's is very high you said
patreon I don't think they have a
patreon page but it's like it's just a
matter of becoming a patron then you can
get the little icon next to your name
hey is it back might be back I get so
excited when the page loads feel like
I'm living in the 1990s but this user
interface is not the 1990s it's just the
slowness of a server Oh glad paid played
penguin ah yeah he's gonna chess too
close you may have closed I mean this
gives me time to drink more tea oh did I
lose a game I probably lost a game
because I was white but that last game
the last game was really nice diamond
cutter overslept that's okay I don't
know yeah if you're just joining I don't
know if this term is gonna complete
successfully I think the plan the plan
should be to run this once the servers
are we're all having the same problem I
mean I have the page loaded but
nothing's nothing's responding
yeah I was watching there's a streamer
something X cow xq cow who's not exactly
a cattle place was streaming chess on me
chess and had like twenty six thousand
people watching on twitch well we just
out of the tournament is canceled very
sorry no reason to think we can fix it
yeah yeah we don't want to torture
people
that's a humane decision yeah well we we
didn't finish in last we fin we finished
almost midway through we finished in
sixth place good job team good job vlad
who is on the team
Oh pots are pots our play was ended in
in frisco pots our play weed SKU yeah
are they going to restart no no it's
it's over I mean the change the stream
title so everyone knows
oh it's music shorts yeah yeah probably
especially especially tangy in the 2700
at least okay at least we can see the
the finish there were three hundred
sixty eight players on the team average
rating just over 1700 yeah good job to
everyone when we see the top fifty JP
was numero fifty do I play any other
games yeah we might get to see that soon
other games
oh how are the wins and losses
calculated so the yeah I don't know if I
actually explained this but the top
twenty scores are added up and then
counted for the team so yeah there there
is a tie for 20th but basically all of
these scores so 20 through the 42 score
are added up and that that would bring
you to the 481 score uh-oh this is a new
page I can't even access the tournament
Oh
Oh maintenance in progress obviously
this is probably a more functional page
than uh than the artwork even though the
artwork was visually appealing at least
we can see the tweets which is crucial
what is this oh this game surrender the
black king press space what you thought
I'd only bring two nights you are
surrounded
never uh-oh what is this oh wait I don't
know if I've done this before oh I just
wow well this is my life now I can move
up to oh I can't move ah that's fancy oh
okay oh this is so interesting to my
zoom in and kind of zoom in oh well I
can not capture it all I can capture
pawns
oh this is so satisfying sound oh wait
how do i how do I break through what I
don't see how I break through no what
how was I supposed to break through that
how do I move diagonally I was using
their Hokies I forgot Kings could move
diagonally I wonder wait let me try this
again maybe I had to click ah so I can
do this okay okay now I had now I
understand let's capture unnecessary
pawns
okay well this is so funny how many
other extremes are doing this right now
ah this is okay let's get rid of these
pawns so I get points for taking pawns
I don't I guess I don't get points yeah
the officer would be so proud of me
right now
[Music]
wait what what is this line
oh I maybe I upgraded levels oh so I
have to take the rook now ah look at
this damn I feel so such like a crow oh
it's gonna get complicated though oh
dear why not take this stuff I wonder if
I were to no I couldn't do that
BAM beem yeah wait I like it through
okay oh the bishop let's just destroy
the bishop what does this call I don't
know whoever Pro ever program this good
job I think this is my life now oh dear
can you move on light squares Oh
thankfully use your mouse I kind of like
the keyboard though I could use a mouse
photo
Oh oh dear taketake petition
this is getting complicated
[Music]
we just needs to have like a high-score
feature with this game cuz I don't know
what I'm working towards what
oh that's go fended wow this is becoming
complicated okay so I keep upgrading
levels what is that it's a spike he's
doing exist in chess so if I step on it
I probably lose this is like oh I have
to maze oh okay I don't leave what oh
that's so sneaky
please can still move diagonally what oh
there you go aha
these spikes are throwing me off I
couldn't figure it out I probably had to
take the bishop which was defending the
knight and then I was so difficult and
what is this I don't know what that was
okay is over 800 people watching that
because we don't know what to do with
our lives can't play chess you go back
all the castle what is this
I was so close I could play again as uh
as a sight back let's see maybe not oh
there is a checkpoint click space
oh it's back I don't know how to act I
don't know if I would know how to access
a page when the site is working people
are so upset me chess is working again I
mean that was leech s's twitter feed so
I assume they were sharing some funny
gif I don't know rookie mistakes gifting
a sub to Mark J Turner thank you
appreciate that
Oh me chest I work / 404 thanks thanks
for the simple link
yeah people want to play that me chess
org slash 404
wait what to do tell me what to do
people do we play I mean I could I could
go back and play that game or could can
I even like check to see the tournament
standings ooh
everything so sad
puzzle simulcast sir variance I don't
wanna I don't wanna repeat the whole
game though yeah it's so deflating when
you work so hard and then you can't get
past the spike thingy then you have to
work your way up again and Scrabble
crazy house geo geo or do I just play
chess straw poll yeah okay hole wonder
how many options I can add to a poll
looks like five what to do your
tournament I can't do a simulcast of
fetch issues with the sign will still
geoguessr i Scrabble
[Music]
I could go back to the what do we call
that game each just about Oryx - 404 or
or just play play viewers
I can allow people to vote with channel
points wait no it's not okay let's just
start the poll so the poll is in the
chat ob chestnut works says any 404 any
404 page will bring up Oh
so bleach a stork slash anything bring
back the the game okay it's good to know
yeah I'll have the chat we can see the
what people want wow people want the 404
game haha over the media viewer
tournament
[Music]
I set the poll to two minutes no tigey
is disappointed that geoguessr is and
people are trolling with fewer term in
the 404 game 63 people want to see the
scheme
okay well I'll try and make it to the
castle I guess and then then I'll do a
viewer tournament how that so I'll play
it I'll play the 404 game and now I'll
do a viewer tournament
oh but if you return it's catching up I
could vote myself let's vote for
Scrabble
oh thanks son oh thanks soggy
oh the the fluorophore game is still
winning 75 votes and the the poll should
be ending momentarily yeah we can see
the timer here Wow
so this will be the order I'll probably
do this I'll probably do the top three
404 game yeah so
oh yeah courtesy of whoever this is good
job Saturn in okay this would be serious
space okay no no no okay there we go
okay so we're gonna capture unnecessary
pawns just to make y'all feel proud this
is such degenerate whatever but it is
fun I do remember likings like this from
childhood
[Music]
so the goal is to make it to the castle
and remember how the King knows Wow I
mean it's the horizon oh there's Brooks
okay let's stay focused
I won't let me go further
most most 1:06 thanks for subbing at
this very weird time of events that's a
checkpoint what oh I have to move on
light sprays remember this this position
oh dear let's take the bishop okay oh
that bishop is so sneaky
let's take it
the nights are also very sneaky what oh
it's defended by the official okay this
is tricky
couch is off gambit like some noises and
noises are very satisfying
so the spikes are just squares I can't
go on they don't attack anything what oh
I did that I did that last time too
that's very sneaky very sneaky Oh what
is this
there you go it's very difficult to
focus these spikes add a whole new layer
of complexity I think this was the last
time I messed up yeah I made this in a
castle
let's go die wind what happens here what
is this
I can't see anything it's blocking my oh
I win oh ok ok what it's just over I
thought something was gonna happen is
reaches back by now I think it's been
back for a little bit yeah I got to to
castle that's the goal of chess
ok well now I think we we can happily
move on and do a viewer tournaments play
tournaments I hope I won't like crash
the site of this great tournament
we'll make it raided what do people want
the team battle is gonna be three
minutes but 500 1000 hey let's do a
polling in
okay so what time control 1 103 oh I
know there's a lot of times in between
well do five it's five plus two and so
one oh three oh five two or ten Oh
[Music]
make this a 1-minute poll okay or oh oh
or four plus four I tried to make
options which won't conflict with each
other like I was thinking to have three
two or five oh but I know it kind of
split the people who just want blitz so
thank you Nash's I love your bits Nash's
but no 100 bits I'll look for one oh
let's see a comeback but probably not so
it's a battle between 5 2 & 3 Oh
interesting
the poll is in the chat
you might have to click this little
thing if you're on mobile it might be
different I don't know
hey 521 oh it's very close so so let's
do five to make it how long do I want to
be here for well make it 70 minutes I
guess I'll try a labas irking although
ABBA's irking actually no no I won a lot
of his irking because I want to have
like some stable decent high quality
chests but how do i how i disable the
zerkin oh there we go
I could restrict it to only title
players that's interesting okay and it
should start wait what oh I didn't oh I
got confused I said it what did I do
I said it to - oh so this will be that
and then this term it will start in two
minutes once I create it my bad okay now
I think it's okay there's no password
this is free to join ok tournaments
sharing the link in the chat and I'm
also updating the tournament commands
okay so you can use the term in command
to trigger the nightbot link Turman
starts in just over 90 seconds
what-what-what's 503 503 what oh did it
break it doesn't look like it bro what's
503 it's working for me
we chess is down let's go
puzzle li chess appears to be working
completely fine unless everyone's
trolling with me I don't know where's my
tournament here it is media's just
working for me and no one else I mean
all the pages are working we might have
to move on to geoguessr but no it's down
for me and EU core kapil says it's
working oh it's down in Germany oh maybe
it's just maybe the European servers are
down
oh but some some people it's down for
and it's down in Maine it's down for the
ice we're gonna see what happens I mean
there's 59 people it's not ton st. Louis
yeah shadows the deep down Philippines
down in India I'm I'm playing maybe no
one else can join link use a tournament
commands night just yeah look look for
the night bots and I thought we'll be
sharing the link
this is gonna be a failed tournament I
don't think I can cancel the tournament
once it starts I mean I have three we
have a London mainline yeah after the
scheme I we'll reevaluate what's
happening
I just it'd be fine a Bishop d3 is like
the most popular move but Bishop e5 in
my opinion is the most venomous and also
it's less common so people don't know
how to react to it and there's a few
yeah a few traps that black and fall
into London any of anyone from London
here uh yeah this is actually probably
one of the best moves but it seems like
the point is clear clearly out of
preparation Queen c7 it's decent like we
need to think after the trade the the
goal is actually to move back and then
to secure the e5 square so a6 I think
just helped me soaking wet size says I'm
from London but don't live there at the
moment
yeah 95 is on the horizon because
sometimes black wants to play e5
and this is nice because and I can't
take is on my fork
if the bishop takes I got the bishop
hair got initiative some idea of about
for wondering what it working like
incognito
it looks like the term in is functioning
for that force committal
but she lets castle first
I wanna play rookie one eventually off
for this is sort of like a Pillsbury
agaric 81f for hey it's oMG alien says
oMG I finally get to see Eric on stream
rather than than YouTube yeah yeah I
made I don't usually make YouTube posts
but I made a youtube post today
promoting the stream battle which maybe
in hindsight was a mistake given that
led to more traffic but yeah good to see
some some YouTube people transitioning
to to twitch and before as a move before
is the type of move I probably just
ignore playoff for I might want my rook
on the Queen side that's the best thing
to do if something's not working you
close it and you reopen it or you unplug
it and then you plug it back in there is
some mean going around that that's what
we should do for for 2020 like the
entire year so far I just try and unplug
it and we plug it back in
[Music]
yeah how many coffee drinkers are there
watching I won't judge you people too
much could do a poll for those of you
just watching trying to enjoy
we'll do a polled coffee or tea take I'm
just curious
make it a five-minute poll okay let's
play
wait let's defend a pawn that was very
sneaky Locke was attacking the pawn yeah
Bishop f2 I mean overall this is a very
typical in London harmony this is
actually a high level in the idea 96 to
e4 which is kind of hard to stop
keep forgetting this was five plus two
as well you're taking doesn't make sense
yeah blocks gonna secure the square
mm-hm
considering c4 here it's an interesting
move it allows a bishop to come to life
some attempt to destabilize black also
play this move you have to pick a line
I didn't make another another option
another option um I guess you could just
go thirsty okay so I'm aligning the
bishop with the Queen I mean there might
be some possible line let's say ninety
four yeah so I was thinking I could take
once I take what the thing is if I take
with the knight pawn takes Bishop moves
f6 traps my Knights
so maybe g5 is the way to go but g5
allows 9f5 I've c4 here idea taking I
think I'll play c4 it might takes D 262
takes let's try it
so there's yeah there's a few things I'm
trying to apply pressure to kind of the
main targets also with the night no
longer on f6 each seven can be more of a
target but for now it's kind of hard to
actually exploit sometimes there's
consequences to generosity
I guess if tog II was being generous in
multiple ways so I wanted to take care
but I think Queen b6 is a problem
counter attacking as calculating Queen
b6 takes takes but should have to but
then Queen takes and running mate and
there's no tricks let's just take
[Music]
yeah I don't really want to trade
thinking about this move got five is a
slightly crazy approach
it could also take with nights you'll
take with nights
I'll take with her it's equal material
but my position is not that great for a
few reasons so I didn't really get any
attack my pawns are overextended so my
King's weak this pawns isolated which is
actually in kind of the strategy these
days is to social distance but not
always the best strategy in chess Queen
g5 is coming which is very hard to stop
thinking h4 King h2 there's also this
move doesn't do much though hey coffee
one coffee one by 51% while is very
close I would have voted for tea it's 75
votes to 72 votes so maybe I should I
think if my audience prefers coffee
maybe I should look for a coffee sponsor
there's a beam one oh I'm low on time
this is not gonna be pretty
there should be one was not a good move
maybe this is a really attack at least
my opponent my opponent has multiple
options yeah that's a decent move oh
that's actually a really good move I'm
just losing
oh no that's not legal
mmm
this is so sad Wow good move
I'm gonna let black meanie in a fancy
way blocks calculating Queen each one
which was interesting I'd like to move
May than one can connect you in the chat
find it painful I think I was in trouble
even like after Bishop e7 is a very very
smart move oh maybe I'm not in trouble
what's the best approach just chill the
slack fish wants to sit on this oh and I
see five ah interesting
okay well I lost the first game I can't
tilt in berserk which is probably a good
thing
and now how we chess heats Brian for
some reason Oh Jasper the pro good game
hello
maybe Lee chess is tilting for me Oh Lee
chess in the chat shadow to each s
report the bug not sure if that would be
the wisest thing to do let's refresh
yeah when you lose a game in your own
viewer tournaments and then it breaks
breaks the whole website internal
service air
Hey
Brian's Brian became a patron today and
to help with this high time of boredom
that's nice
yeah no it's actually very impressively
czesc and has been sustained just solely
on community support and it remains free
and high quality at least most of the
time high quality Dobby chess is a
social media guy aha I can't help much
with servers I can only go on Twitch and
try and smooth things over
yeah it's not about approach
yeah kudos to leech s and their their
social media though what are the counts
there's a twitch account there's YouTube
they've been more active with YouTube
actually no there there's been some she
a good deal of contents for four
candidates a lot of different streamers
doing content for them
of course twitch and then the reporting
to like their their coverage on
candidates as well as Reggie in chess I
think Smee yachts for the advice I
haven't had coffee in a long time
Starbucks close down there are a few
days where Starbucks was still open but
they removed all the cherries now
they're just closed are you sure there's
a coffee machine somewhere in this
apartment it'll be just the social
distancing yeah that's one way to repel
people I did go through a poker face
I've never streamed poker though i've
streamed choker i had a matching ins
nakamura played choker uh
taggi yeah taggi knows knows what to do
when it comes to poker no in college i I
didn't like play a decent amount of
poker
I just cynical cash games I took it
seriously but just as more that's very
nice thanks for that pregnant you have
lad Vlad knows what to do Geo guess your
time
I forgot to change the stream title Oh
someone did it for me though thanks
whoever did that for me
some kind of man do we have any mods
there's gotta be mods here yeah there's
at least Hoggy yeah shout out to the
moms oh the ice yeah the ice is so so
quick and smart
oh and Sonya what's up Sonya can you go
on chasuble or chess pastes so yeah I
have chess base here very briefly I do
have chess base I've been working on
like a Stafford gambit I don't know what
I'll do with it if I'll put them on
chesil or I'll just make a free like me
just study but I've been working on kind
of building outs more organized
annotated analysis mites might do some
video content so stay tuned for it well
I want to do something a bit more more
organized they're coming coming weeks
and probably months maybe years anyway
yeah let's change the stream title yet
again and I think we're gonna switch
away from some chests but I will be
seeking feedback probably over coming
days and weeks in terms of what people
want I mean there there's a lot of
demand for some gambits courses or
videos yeah don't go to Geo now why also
that was just base 15
as a turn it back no I'll probably still
be doing geo in 50 minutes don't worry
okay I mean just the pain so yeah I'm on
the side Oh probably because I was
streaming Scrabble okay scrapple first
Scrabble lost the poll terribly what to
do hey another son Vasile via nose
thanks for subbing let's play the world
I usually play diverse world
let's do world this is kind of the
hardest do like 2 minutes and 30 seconds
why not did I break HS or it was maybe
it was people whoa it's admiral Admirals
back gifting subs
welcome back Admiral the burner thanks
so much
this is there's a time limit here
also this is very low quality um this
feels like Australia I would think I
don't know if we're gonna be whole to
explore too much this could be South
Africa though yet so this is good point
because you you can see the compass
compass is right here I should move mine
I mean if people can see it so because a
sign is more in the North we're in the
southern hemisphere so I guess either
South Africa or Australia
but the Admiral gifting subs to Prasanna
good Dan squid Rev qxx empty wave
function and ow
Alex and dr. something oh yeah yeah tog
II is always have to listen to tog II
the trees look African yeah oh yeah I
don't really want to debate I know like
there's there's all this like
controversy in debate I know I mean that
there the day that tournament got
postponed they had every single possible
like Grand Master being interviewed on
on all the broadcasts giving their
thoughts and opinions but yeah I'm
probably not gonna be in too much on the
controversy but yeah I do encourage
people if you want to get the opinions
of the top top chess players in the
world I mean the chest 24 broadcasts the
st. Louis broadcasts chess talk on
broadcast I mean there is Kramnik
Carlsen red Java the feed a president
feed a general well I forgot to make a
guess also it was I forgot it was timed
- uh-huh
no one reminded me except you're
reminding me now because of the slight
delay
back sorry we just crashed during your
tournament it happens we'll all take
responsibility okay actually we're in
some nice place
oh thanks so much so we're in Russia
some city in Russia let's see if we have
any clues any Russians you people from
Russia watching and tell me where this
is Yanni punny my you play ruski I don't
understand Russian there's a club
it could be Ukraine actually but no
hablo Ukrainian either
yeah we're somewhere we're somewhere in
this part of the world probably Sochi
did you see Sochi where is Sochi
something something zoomy zoomy theater
also where's Sochi so she's like a chess
place it could be Sochi okay also
where is Sochi so cheese is that
Ukrainian or Russia
so she's in Russian okay my geography my
knowledge of like Russian cities is not
so great
Russia is so big I don't know where to
look for Sochi Southwest dish Southwest
Russia can I find Sochi near Georgia oh
here
Oh Sochi so we're kind of close to the
coast what was left either let's find
the theater they have only a few seconds
left
Zim needs heater okay so we're looking
for a Zuni Theatre in Sochi here's what
here's a theater it was a IMAX theater
but where's a Zuni theater okay let's
just make the guests somewhere somewhere
here hey good job two miles away who
knew it was so like how did you know it
was so Chi
hey it's Neil welcome back no ands Ches
pay thanks people for for being here so
Zuni theater like on the map
I don't know how people knew it was
Sochi but maybe yeah if you can read
Russian I don't know okay
well this makes up for the first round
where I forgot to guess ok new place ok
so we have two and a half minutes hmm we
go down the hill or up the hill gastrin
gastronomic on so that person up the
hill yeah there's there's things up here
the talk shop and the bottle store or
Tia T&F bottle store so people are
wearing turquoise I'll color you see
everyday
everything's turquoise Wow turquoise was
my favorite color what Wasaga US flag is
this s CGA
this is some stand country right or is
it no oh it's you it's you it's the
European Union
I knew that okay so is it Romania
there's Romania part of the year no uu
Romania is outside of the Schengen zone
I'm pretty sure it illegal and unsafe so
there's a call center don't know what
this means
I'm feeling like Eastern Europe but
somewhere in the EU and somewhere that
speaks a decent amount of English let
fou grocery store okay
oh maybe Schengen zone and EU are
different are we driving on the left
oh good points yeah we're drivable what
country in the so we're not in the EU
were probably in South Africa where's
the Sun the sun's in the North we're in
South Africa right we're not in UK I
don't think I mean we could be but more
turquoise suits
let's go South Africa
oh I was s WA teeny s what Tina is like
a sneaky country that's somehow it snuck
in to like the interior of South Africa
well South though is even more sneaky
that's what teeny Wow okay so we got
kind of in the right right range of
things well back in the day it was
called Swaziland interesting okay I'm
feeling Brazil just looting me Alexa
what does sleuthing mean that's what
good it
oh thank you gastrin on subbing a
tier-one
where was that sign I swear I saw a sign
so here here it is what does it say a
deepest point indicates deepest point I
don't know what this means
also where's the Sun what which
hemisphere are we in the Sun doesn't
really give us any clues because yeah
it's just kind of in the the West it
seems like are we in Australia we could
be on Australia chest we besides
Australia its chest by Jay here we need
we need a true Australian eastern
Australia somewhere below sea level
are we driving on the left oh no because
I don't know like this is a 360 tag bond
tag bonds here yeah people who are here
help me
Australia or New Zealand someone was
saying tag on is sleeping hot Iceland I
think stalking not really making
progress on this road oh it's a curve so
we're going north and the curves what's
going on go into Australia going north
and then a curve so let's go here I
don't think we're gonna get too many
more clues it's uh there's a flood way
does it flood in Australia oh wait East
da was north yeah
someone said East I got I got my east
and west west mixed up it was north
northern Australia it was near the dude
Barra Gregory National Park
okay we got the country at least
but 2600 kilometers away man it's
difficult hey there's a rough and
there's what languages us Chinese
Chinese characters I'm feeling Taiwan
but maybe Japan so bad I can't
distinguish between like Japanese and
Chinese characters
okay Japan kanji what's kanji
okay people say in Japan so I'll
probably have to listen to people or
driving normal side okay
the thing about China is most of China
is not on Google Maps Oh kanji is
Japanese characters let's get a road
sign I'm not sure yeah I have not
actually checked if there's gonna be a
problem with the Mozart music okay so
we're on 477 let's go into Japan he goes
she me yeah okay I just want to find one
of these places for 77
looking for coca people sing nor the
northern Japan Japan goes pretty far
ignoring coca and yo I'm looking for a
place not seeing any
no South Nagasaki but we're looking for
a place on the sign
just guess somewhere
I don't know you passed type asset where
da o is more people were saying north or
south by the central it's like smack in
the center east of Kobe huh oh these
were like smaller places there's 477
[Music]
okay what to do it's tough at the time
limit do one more maybe pass 199 how's
it going yeah if you're joining right
now you've you've missed so much let's
do one more I'll do you don't keep it a
minute or two minutes and 30 okay we're
in
Renea I believe P o-tar you welcome back
yeah we're doing at least two more this
is Philippine Philippines right
peso
oh wait maybe this is this feels like
Asia
it's an Indonesian or Philippines or
Palazzo
or New York it's trying to have some
kind of clue Pancho was there a sign for
palawan palawan ah good call tog II
palawan ah palawan punt
okay so let's find the pawn shop where
to go hear this and we're in some more
populated area it seems like a
mountainous country but I don't see any
mountains what's the biggest city
maybe the ports it's not loading
okay so we're gonna just guess somewhere
this road goes north to south and then
curves
well guessed like somewhere here San
Jose Philippines yeah I'm I'm aware of
the time see if we can find any like
landmark type thing on the wrong Island
I'm on palawan palawan
and we're gonna guess oh you were right
but it said palawan here and I saw the
poll all when Tom's punch up Oh
San Jose good job tiny
hmm I mean yeah it's still not bad but
confused why why it said palawan
pawnshop and we weren't in Palawan do
you guys want mozart's you want more
tart let me know well we're moving on
that's not a bad start
Oh takis girlfriend lives in the
Philippines I've never been to the
Philippines probably won't be able to go
for probably at least another year
okay there's there's cattle Alexa play
Mozart's so we're driving on the right
side where's the Sun Alexa play Mozart
music yeah I only learned like recently
Mozart has a first name or how the first
name is a US no but maybe the Sun didn't
really help us
Europe could be like France or Spain or
South America
oh there's a bridge
did the car was their car I didn't see a
car of Colombia
wanted to cross the bridge but okay I'll
trust the chat that meet either the
Carson escolar oh yeah there was a car
because I knew we knew which which side
we're driving up
yeah South America seems like a decent
area
I'm like near some mountains Gus here
and keep driving hopefully find
something
Alexa louder
is it Europe should I listen to tagging
Tijuana
don't flag ah I don't know sticking with
Colombia da who said Southeast Brazil as
its in Southeast Brazil you have to
listen to as it hmm well plane got the
continent okay I think we're backing
somewhere in Asia this could be
Philippines again let's see this sign or
this could be some spanish-speaking
country so some small municipal ports
trying to read Spanish looking for clues
is this not Spanish oh is this is uh
this is Brazil do you narrow were in
Brazil right it's Portuguese yeah
Portuguese so we're in Brazil again
where's-where's a-okay Rio de Janeiro
so it says Rua Oh like the road Rose
Road in Portuguese I think but we could
be we could be in this kind of we find a
road named into Janeiro
let's keep exploring we have a minute
left
Obie chess servers are restarting in
nine minutes nice
no this is definitely Brazil but where
where to go
[Music]
trying to find like some highway sign or
something it's possible does this say
Santa this could be like a city or town
named Santa Taryn Xenia
I don't know let's just guess
much further north
[Music]
that was tough
what did you yeah I'm going to try and
avoid dirty flagging okay we're driving
on the right side where's the Sun Sun is
straight above and no help it seems like
a really nice location though pluggy
says Spain yeah the road is in very good
shape this looks like reindeer crossing
[Music]
let's just follow this car and see where
it's going
yeah definitely some European vibes
I don't think we're in California
because there are speed limit signs in
kilometers I would not mind like taking
a road trip in this area of the world oh
it's a bus a Sarah a Sarah deal man I
swear in the EU Spain seems most likely
Vlad gifted by Admiral thanks Admiral
and things flat for sticking around Otto
Carius
that's my only clue really interrogating
that bus I'm not familiar with like most
areas of Spain do we go
I mean it's very hilly and go like
somewhere on the don't flag and try not
to [ __ ] don't mess up some people sing
northern Spain I was in northern Spain I
thought northern Spain is more
mountainous what is this it's a statue
of something ah guess is about to flag
that was further north Oh near Burgos
someone was saying Burgos Wow good job
two people who said Burgos have to trust
oh we have we have some Spaniards in the
chat's Spanish people okay not that got
the country local camera quality I think
the next round I'll play diverse worlds
I don't know if I want to explore this
place thanks so much
this could be us actually looks like a
stop sign
[Music]
okay we'll go with you us
but we're in the u.s. Arizona meeting or
no we're in
there's pine trees maybe the Appalachian
somewhere so mountains pine trees yeah
it's not Arizona
and we're probably on the east towards
the East Coast
[Music]
Pennsylvania's and interesting gusts
camera quality so low though
in Montana also very possible
but
No
[Music]
okay I'm gonna go from
[Music]
just want like some states place this or
something
[Music]
yeah we're gonna go with who is that the
Admirals home states so what does chest'
face a Montana does not have those
delicious trees okay let's guess yay 152
oh it was New York Wow
I forgot that New York exists as a state
and has more than just a city you don't
associate New York with like mountains
and forests good job people hey got a
better score them previously
[Music]
so let me um let's do some some quicker
rounds well that was Brian ah ya think
yeah good job Brian
except that wasn't Pennsylvania's New
York close enough okay so now we're
doing diverse world diverse world there
will be larger diversity of places and
it'll be better counter quality too I
could do some of the other maps so dude
don't sue me
also yeah mr. Nick crybaby thanks for
thanks for the Sun okay there's people
see what the people look like
hmm feels like Eastern Europe Lithuania
lives I could support that follow follow
and turn on notifications you can do
that in your twitch dashboard let's find
Lithuania welcome back Sam thanks for
joining
yet again let's go here ok was it was
Ukraine yeah lift away neo is a more
adventurous guess I know there there's
at least a few Lithuanian viewers I
think I've also I'm trying to get in the
habit of tweeting and I might I might
connect stream labs with Twitter if I
can figure that out
[Music]
so you could follow me on Twitter I'm
also also my stream schedule I think I
have a schedule command thanks chest
page for sharing the notification link
any scheduled streams all I'll put in my
my stream schedule
[Music]
it seems like a really nice place but
where are we would be like first I
remember Sam yeah someone was actually
asking about that yeah I'll follow up
like maybe an email
oh let's Austria Austria I guess yes
okay it was Slovenia Austria was my my
first impression well not bad 99 miles
thought that had for a last second guess
almost forgot to guess okay now we have
very flat road again like Eastern
European vibes was this place
it's kind of colorful Russia could be
Russian
everyone says Russia a Lada what are a
lot of car is L a da everyone says
Russia but we're in Russia Russia is a
big country hungry also may be possible
central Russia like go Ukraine ok we'll
go we'll go we'll compromise hey not bad
another kind of last minute guess it was
closer to Ukraine but still in Russia so
the compromise wasn't bad good job again
chef very good job this is a good round
so far over 12,000 with two more rounds
left if someone said Moldova shoutout to
the Slavs yeah
it's two episodes lots of things were
not allowed to do okay
it does feel European yeah this is a
power of mozart's what's hard is
bringing in the good vibes this is not
America no let's see what the sign says
wait was there a sign I swear I saw a
sign there maybe there's no sign it's a
sign
I don't know somewhere in Europe I was
South Africa Oh what did I guess I guess
Germany small faces I was rushed
I was South Africa well he's winning
doubt in South Africa should have looked
for the Sun - ooh
taggi are we in Iceland this has to be
Iceland this already looks really
photogenic see what the sign says oh
nice yeah taki taki where are you also
where's Iceland and what is this place
I mean this could be no this has to be
Iceland but what are these letters VAT
vats Ferran our das boil by oh I know
that's almost as boardgames
southwest
[Music]
not bad 30 miles pretty good
closer to rake yeah closer to Reykjavik
oh is actually I think this is on the
this is a Golden Circle Drive right
[Music]
do they still call that call it down
Iceland Golden Circle Drive I pretty I
probably driven on this road
I've definitely driven on this road I
wonder if I can find let me see if I can
find me the video is from Iceland it's
on my Facebook somewhere just want to
share a quick video of driving through
Iceland was this or the silent bits
which still kind of made noise videos
I want to share a video but don't think
I can find it yeah oh here this me see
if I can doesn't look like I can access
it
see oh I can make a public
[Music]
you're this okay oh it's very low
quality because Facebook Facebook kind
of killed the quality
[Music]
so this is my my drive somewhere in
Iceland it was uh I was driving rake was
it rate chains National Park like horses
as such a scenic drive to anyway that
sounded like the start of like a serious
serious announcement
anyway let's do one more let's do one
more let's do an ultra speed run 20
seconds chat you can still help but you
have to be very quick okay
first place mmm
we're sweden maybe Sweden or Norway I
don't know somewhere in Scandinavia chat
Sweden Sweden Sweden where Sweden let's
go 117 miles
good job chat Sweetman yeah when you see
colourful houses sometimes you can just
assume Scandinavia okay another one what
does it say Santa some
[Music]
this is probably something moon isn't
Mexico or Spain I don't know it's go
Spain I weigh 153 it was oh it was
Puerto Rico
no one said someone said not Spain with
Puerto Rico oh that's a tough one
it's a really tough one chassé pesos for
Yuriko you know okay next one
[Music]
working the speed there's no time
[Music]
maybe Eastern Europe again
I don't know Estonia it's probably - oh
is Lithuania not bad that's pretty good
nice over 4000 points to another ooh
where is this it's not too much time
this could be like Jordan Lebanon UAE
it's good like Jordan
I was someone said you AE
Rodan
now it was just the geography to go by
okay
got some more points oh the roads were
too good I didn't recognize that a
rolling wheel how's it going a rolling
wheel is the one to listen to Oh what is
this this is Japan right
or is this is that Korean no it's Japan
right
where's Japan but where and go like safe
and central I was much far north
yeah Japan is very high on my bucket
list places together in the north yeah
okay oh that was it
well do one more one more on that maybe
Scrabble 20 seconds let's beat the score
of whatever twelve thousand that was
what where is this Tunisia I don't know
Tunisia one which way we're facing with
Chile Oh Brian Fallon - oh h5 London the
eye of the journey trap did anyone say
chillin rolling wheel nice nice job it
just it was just a pure desert road got
18 points for that area 51 man tough
Santa Cruz New Mexico maybe no wait
where's Santa Cruz in real life
Mexico rights but where's Santa Cruz
Nola's Bolivia Oh Bolivia Santa Santa
Cruz Old Mexico oh this is this is rough
or in another weird place this looks
like per could be Peru again or Chile or
Mexico I don't know don't know who to
listen to
Hey okay Oh is Bolivia but close enough
is Egypt on Google Maps I'm not sure
does this say
[Music]
somewhere I have no idea so somewhere
South America
I'm like I don't know Uruguay Oh Spain
it was it was Spain oh is endora
actually Zen Dora yeah yeah it looked
like a really nice indoors like a really
nice country which I've never been to I
was very tricky Chow space had Portugal
which is closer something Brazil but
we're in Brazil chaffed tell me
Noorie okay bow South okay summary as a
rough one was very rough
wow it's admirable 1000 bits will do I'm
doing my best
yeah slight self isolating and sticking
the chess geoguessr and now maybe time
for Scrabble Scrabble was last in the
poll from earlier but might as well play
a few games to wrap things up
[Music]
Scrabble time one more just for tigey
just for tigey just because you asked
did you ask politely you didn't say
please but it's okay
ten seconds ten seconds diverse world
who knows maybe this will all just be
Europe let's go
some oh there's ten seconds Poland
pretty good was hungry shout out to the
hungry people in the chest ten seconds
is not a lot of time I have no idea
let's go again Europe
North Macedonia yeah so far it's just
Europe so tigey's getting his wish
okay no way this is Europe where is this
South America and Chile Argentina still
racking up points and ten-second
speedrun is is not easy
oh whoa Pizza Pizza Zoo let's go maybe
Latvia
how was Italy oh of course
Pizza how did I not get that oh that's
good to hear
I'll return to me chess probably in the
future Street Alexa played Beethoven Fur
Elise by Sylvie Chava and Ludwig van
Beethoven on Amazon music okay last this
is the last one right there's no time
let's go like maybe France Switzerland
Austria what it was Tasmania this
doesn't mean
[Music]
I got one point for that one point play
Alexa louder Alexa louder
[Music]
okay it's time of you summary almost got
to 10,000 which is not bad for 10
seconds speed run i will brainstorm
maybe some other game possibilities oh
look into I've actually never done
scribble that sounds interesting
well we're gonna wrap things up with a
Scrabble run
let me move myself okay
[Music]
lay out it's decent
let's play I just want to play a blitz
keen play this person five minutes if
you not familiar with Scrabble it's a
word game
it's something I've I've been
competitive in recently these are
terrible letters don't play this it's
too late but play there there's a word
on the wall it helps to know that these
weird obscure words especially it helps
to know words with lots of vowels but my
these letters are complete garbage
[Music]
it's fij alert also I'm playing a
version without challenges fij is the
word ladders are still garbage I'm
scoring points which is good
myself further yeah I know there's
there's probably people watching who may
be English is not their first language
but maybe you can still follow along oh
this is great I've for you right now
it's a 12-hour charity event hosted by
twitch and Amazon music okay Alexa quiet
was it weird look at that teepee I got
rid of for ease that's so nice
got rid of all my garbage letters and I
still have only slight garbage I didn't
know Alexa will just randomly advertise
things to you anyway um yeah I still I
still have to get rid of stuff I do have
the Z which can be used to score points
well it's a very difficult board I have
a zero now I'll have words but it's hard
to find places to play it
um I wanna get rid of the sea somehow if
Rho is rogue earth yogurt no rogue is a
word that nowhere to play it
I'll play rug who though is a nice word
tonight it was Roger a word check
Oh Roger was yeah Rogers valid yeah I
got rid of the you sometimes annoying
tile that's a hard word
and behind in score too
if wheeler wheeler or iller okay boiler
that's a dangerous play because if the
opponent has a B they can play boiler
and then go down that would be scary oh
but there's no bees left or might be
coiler toiler should be a word you just
really want to get rid of my Z
like toiler and there's really not much
to play even with the Z I'm jealous
[ __ ] yeah there's only two bees and
scrabble is Nelia word okay
got the double word there okay now now I
can score probably swore a lot on my
next play of Qi us or zas yeah let's do
this
his rouga google should be a word
so kudo is not a wearing but qi it's uh
i think it means life force there's
something like that
a she let's play have all these
high-scoring tiles
please Zola any A's are left okay
those wondering how many A's are left
cuz I'll have za and then something like
I could even play a lakhs and ox 440
which could be very nice or wax yeah
maybe somehow waxy okay so I took the
lead it's 212 to 190 I do have links to
yeah links is a nice word but probably
nowhere to put it
yeah let's go for a wax 46 ooh
seems like there may be close to using
all the letters here canapé not seeing
anything so clear let's play just let's
play play no let's play a pay cut the PM
the triple Wow
I've inclined okay so inclined is one
bingo but I I do have somewhere to play
a to or no I don't I don't
and both wakes
yeah my rating my Scrabble rating is
slightly lower than my chest rating but
I think in general Scrabble the ratings
are lower than typing the best these are
the highest rated players on the server
I guess I'm not well maybe it's not
entirely the best I don't see myself
there let's play coiler
now I actually don't see a seven-letter
play of Lices
wow this is this is actually really
frustrating if ing it's kennelly Willard
well I've Cannella
I don't know what that means but I have
it let's go
no it's not validated okay there we go
Canella as ing suffix is very nice to
know a lot so what does Cannella mean
Kenneth Lee is a community of ten
thousand four hundred fifty nine
inhabitants in the province of asking
you know Alexa what doesn't know a mean
meowing is a form of the word me out
every no Meah are usually defined as the
characteristic sound a cat makes as a
verb meow is usually defined as to make
this horrific rat form or ask me to give
you more definitions for me out it's
known as smelling word - Alexa what does
smelling mean in England the name no he
means from heaven in Greece the name
Noah means one who is bright in France
the name is Alexa quiet Ellen it's hard
to ask Alexa not obscure words when you
don't know how to pronounce them I
didn't win this game I don't yeah I'm
gonna win this game
it's 402 to 96 I'm stuck with the O's
you play Oh
[Music]
I think oho is a word oho I'll go out
with how like Wang Wang how yeah what
does compelling me I assume the K is
silent it's a verb meaning to bring
solemnly especially for a death or a
funeral
and what does smelling me smelling
definition o to tire fasten interesting
[Music]
tigey says ooh ha yeah okay
good game gain some rating points 16:34
overall I think yeah I mean I started
out with garbage letters but I was able
to score
I liked TP not every day you get to use
for ease in a six letter word
I also happy I could have used three e's
an epi pen
should I play let's do like one more
game I'll play another 5 min the King
playing connection oh I'm playing the
same person oh good luck I realize this
the same person Oh a P is a fencing
weapon oh yeah there's a few meanings
the worst two letter combination in
Scrabble is w and you at least one of
the words there's so few words with W
and and you oh it's my turn oh I didn't
realize drown
no problems not a word
um play on something I'll just play it's
my power like Kapow Oh chest bass says
uptown I missed it I probably wouldn't
play that cuz I I would not have seen
that just stay stay somewhat fair
there's must don't really want to use my
ass but that's worth some points also
this is the word ohm ohm and Munt play
this word keeping us again I have a
blank I have potential for ing Z it's
gonna be hard so you use all the letters
with just a Z Tzu is not a word pretty
sure illness can be plural honest thing
is I don't have any vowels I don't
really want to use my bling as a vowel
oh but this is nice so I could play zing
XI so I was Inge
during if there's anything better
losing is probably the way to go I was
looking for like if the see if the Z
were a CI I would have tracings but yeah
just let's just please your neck
okay so I have rotates the very least
I've toast her I also have a toaster in
the kitchen make some toast
so where to put it
I'll just play rotates rotates is nice
the double word back to some garbage
letters good plays ooh 20 that gave us
both my vowels I would like to use a J
somewhere beware
I could trade
- do you just like jots or Johnno jolts
jolts for so many points forty points so
I got the J on the double letter and the
double word house nice there's not too
many four-letter words that end with J
trying to think the only word that would
end with James H ad J okay what to do
use a B and play like this but it's
difficult I think now it's time for zoo
I kind of set up a triple or the point
has a an ER and no oh I have a cool word
but it's it's a dumb word I'll play it
anyway it's a cool word burr this was
recently added to the dictionary okay so
I have about a 50 point lead uh that was
a good play by opponent I'm not fond of
my letters play something like 20 yeah
there's not too many words are without
vowels while opponents poni has come
back of play aha 4:28
one clave just kind of making up words
here no play cave for 25 almost have
Cajun but not really I'll have much time
left either it's been so much time
earlier like cave it sets off my
opponents but scored some points I'm in
the lead temporarily I know what's in
the bag all the X's in the bag that
would be a terrible play and set up e^x
to do play Joe
I wasn't sure what to do
plate ion still slightly in the lead but
the board is becoming more difficult my
next play will be a the Y here to Luke
while with a word okay so I'm still in
the lead I want to use the a like a B
and then probably like plea unclean no a
pyah pyah like that that would open up
too much though
yeah there's Luna but plea will will
score a little bit more his son tale no
one's taking time what's in the bag
so I have to be very wary of the ex okay
increasing my lead
oh yeah that kind of hurts but I managed
424 wow it's gonna be very close
opponent has almost all vowels I don't
want to drop below zero because then
I'll lose 10 points my next play will be
run opponent might take that spot though
looking for ways to go out like okay
let's play run and now I'll go out next
turn yeah I'm gonna win this game it was
close one was very close yeah I won by
seven points GG do I play one more can
play one more
I'll some tea it's challenging me let's
play one more I don't like these letters
let's change all of them the reason for
changing all of them is there's more
likelihood to get the blink which I
don't get but I got the Z please Zen
it's healthier no I have a nice saw I'm
very typical suffix ER if there's an SI
there would be Shelley er how about
Heller Heller is good both are valid its
way Hillier 28 like having to use you as
a dumb novel as za it's um it's slang
for pizza and yeah I believe is this
spelling of the letter L it might have
multiple definitions oh I don't think
julu is a word a jewel vampire chicken
with our aid thanks vampire chicken
shout out so the one only chicken I'm
streaming Scrabble now maybe what some
people are not used to these letters are
not not so promising play like June
[Music]
Jules is spelled with an O actually I'll
play on I know what to play on play Jew
helps to know these nifty small words oh
you've been talking up my big Scrabble
skills oh dear now there's more pressure
I like these letters I have the blank I
have ing but it's a difficult board I
played you again hmm
don't only get to long time this came
you don't really see a super promising
play I want to get rid of the you and
the why I can play smug a smug oh these
letters are not all I'd like to see like
I see there's not too many words that
end with a V there's a few three-letter
words lu v holiday v VA v yeah I see ur
would be would be a nice way if there's
an open are even like here I don't want
to use the blank though but possible to
get the triple I did some selling ass I
assume smooth ones house mugs is not
valid cuz smog like is an adjective so
there's no setup that's actually not an
easy board not too many words on with V
not too many words I'm with F it's hard
to find a word five letter word that
starts with I I have isiliye to ISIL II
would score more but leave myself a
three vowels ones taking time oh I
didn't even realize my opponent played
bingos that's such a great word because
bingo and Scrabble is using all seven
letters smudgy is spelled with two G's I
can check it them
and now what to what to do is lycée no I
really don't know what to do
I couldn't exchange I might just play
like get rid of an eye on me lady I'm
some more balanced track it's important
to have balance between my consonants
and vowels also check the bag I'll have
more consonants and vowels in the bag so
a voice a voice you word yeah a voice
could be useful let's say I almost have
ivory some catching up to do hmm it's
not easy
want to play chiller but nothing to do
there okay there's very close to bingo
here something ending with why
I'm not gonna look at the chat because
I'm sure there's a sudden letter word
here but I don't want to get like unfair
help I might just get rid of the Y even
if there is a bingo it might be hard to
find somewhere to put it let's get rid
of the wine
okay now I've raciest iest raciest like
this
there's 77 looking for other places this
is pretty good okay
yeah that was a nice play cuz if there
weren't too many places to play a seven
other word I'm still behind but it's
very close I have the Q now one scores
yes no D what to do
like tens dunks
I've qat I've kadhi oh this will be a
nice play and it saves it ones also
getting a long time
so the way this works if they fall below
a minute they lose ten points and then
if they've run out of time they lose
this is a very very kadhi okay so
there's no blanks left there's one s
left and there's slightly more
consonants I'm probably gonna fall below
time to just play like goddess or
something up by 10 points but if I fall
below advantage goes away I've screwed
[Music]
da is valid so I'll play screwed if the
spot stays open let's go let's go
screwed okay now I'm definitely gonna
win over the opponent that one's not
gonna use all whole letters oh yeah
points also on the verge of flagging
trying to avoid flagging here myself hey
Aki each one okay was a nice my scheme
hi ya lu v i think it's just another one
of these slang words anyway that was fun
[Music]
so i had i to seven letter planes
raciest and screwed opponent had bingos
which was impressive
oh the link is on yeah if you guys want
to play it's kind of an outdated
interface but it does work is cor oh
it's an internet Scrabble club and yeah
there's different dictionaries to play
with too I think
TW TW il is like the standard I guess
American and then there might be some UK
version there's a multi which
encompasses all languages which is just
insane so you can choose your language
but yeah there there's an official
scrabble dictionary in there are the
Scrabble world is it's also its own kind
of a universe there's a lot of
similarities I think to the chess world
I'm not sure if there's Icelandic
Scrabble there could be maybe I don't
know why is it hosted in Romania I have
no idea it's just a simple simple sight
to remember anyway um yeah that was fun
maybe I'll try and and keep climbing and
get to 700 at some points I think I'm
actually at my all-time close to my
all-time best rating best rating is 1649
I could play another but I've been I've
been streaming for a long time I know
today was supposed to be the team battle
there were issues with with we chess
I'll be back soon with probably more
chests maybe some other games too I
appreciate the fact that you asked
politely I don't know what Ludo is I
don't know how to play it I'm also
hungry but that's something I'll look
into off stream just send me a link and
I'll investigate it but yeah thanks
Brian for shaking around thanks to you
again scribble it's another game while
looking to know there's there's been a
lot of suggestions a lot of ways to to
enjoy things Oh what to do
what's today today Saturday okay let's
turn to read sons arrayed to the Gotham
[Music]
looks like he's playing actual chess
I do appreciate so many people sticking
around through hook through chest
through geoguessr and the various things
yeah having a day people stay safe and
I'll be back in the future